welcome
everyone um we have the
pleasure today of having professor
elena fiden cosmetics from university
college london
she is the professor in migration and
refugee studies at the
geography department
in at ucl in the uk
she's the co-director of the ucl
migration research unit and is the
founder and director
of the institute of advanced studies
refugee
in a moving world research research
network across
ucl uh so professor kazmiya
she has a vast
experience um focusing
um on
[Music]
the study of the refugees
and the intersection between gender
generation and religion in context of
conflicts induced displacement
with a particular focus on the middle
east and
north africa she has conducted
extensive research in refugee camps and
urban areas included in algeria
cuba egypt france jordan lebanon south
africa
syria sweden and the uk
drawing on a critical theoretical
perspective her work contributes to key
debates surrounding refugees experiences
of conflict-induced displacement
the nature of refugee donor relations
and both
north-south and south-south humanitarian
resources
to force migration her current research
examines southern actor responses to
displacement from syria
including responses developed by local
host communities and refugees
themselves so let's uh welcome professor
feytian krasmille and she will be
first giving her presentation and
she will be taking questions at the end
wonderful thank you so much um for your
very warm words of welcome and thank you
for inviting me
thanks to all of you for for joining um
this session i know there are many
competing demands on your time so
i'm very glad to um to see so many
names in squares um on on my screen
um so today i'm going to be speaking um
on the topic of refugee-led responses to
overlapping precarities
and focusing on a particular refugee
camp in north lebanon
and in so doing i'll be drawing on um
two articles um which are themselves
based on
long-standing research um so these
articles were published last year um
firstly in the journal of palestine
studies which focuses
in particular on the evolving situation
um with reference to
um coronavirus covert 19 from
march to june in in badawi refugee camp
in north lebanon
and the second piece which is
co-authored with yusuf mustafa kasmir
who was himself born in badawi refugee
camp um is an article that was published
in
current history and focuses in part
on the events surrounding the post um
beirut
blast in august 2020 and again how
um how this has affected people who've
experienced displacement
and are responding to overlapping crises
effectively in their neighborhoods
these articles are themselves informed
by
long-standing research as i've mentioned
including two research projects
refugee hosts and southern responses to
displacement
which i've been leading since 2016 with
a team of
colleagues of researchers in lebanon
jordan and turkey
as well as in europe and which have been
exploring how people
groups organizations in the middle east
amongst other places have been
responding to displacement from syria
since
2011 and as i hope
is increasingly recognized by now far
from being
passive recipients of humanitarian aid
people who have experienced displacement
um are themselves always already finding
ways to respond
to the challenges that they face and
also to help
others in the same situations and in
those projects refugee hosts
and southern responses to displacement
we start from the premise
that the residents of neighborhoods
which are hosting refugees
have often experienced displacement and
false migration in the past themselves
and indeed may well face displacement
again in the future
so this effectively means that people
who are currently labeled as refugees
were are and will be hosts and the ways
that histories of displacement
intersect with histories of hosting have
important implications
for both the present and the future and
in my research this means
um increasing attention to different
forms
of refugee refugee relationality which
is a term that i use to explore these
relationships between people who have
been been displaced
and that includes a focus on refugees
hosting refugees
and on a broader range of refugee-led
responses to displacement
and indeed their responses to more than
displacement
and this focus on the more than
displacement i think is important
um for a number of reasons and um this
focus on
the refugee refugee relationality in the
context of
displacement and more than displacement
is important because
solely focusing on and providing aid to
newly displaced people or people who
have just experienced a crisis in the
short term as it were
can discriminate against those who are
living in protracted
situations of displacement whose
vulnerability may increase
over time and this is one of the key
challenges that i think that we face
when policy and practice is often
characterized by
what we can call a presentist bias that
is only focusing on
and responding to the new crisis
situation
rather than thinking more carefully
about intersecting and overlapping forms
of precarity
so when we think about these overlapping
procarities
and the increasing vulnerability over
time
unfortunately the situation in lebanon
um demonstrates this
very clearly so we can start by noting
of course that displacement from syria
um to lebanon um may have started in
2011 but of course
takes place on top of long-standing
protracted displacements both internally
and
internationally when we then look at the
events
of 2020 we see that these starkly
illustrate in the case of lebanon
the ways that vulnerabilities can be
accentuated by intersecting crises
such as the covet 19 pandemic which has
afflicted the country since march
and which has led to a range of
xenophobic and discriminatory
responses including discriminatory
curfews on refugees
politicians demanding camp closures and
falsely asserting that refugees were
vectors of disease under
um contagion when in fact we know that
covert 19
arrived in lebanon through lebanese
citizens travel from
italy and iran but using this well-worn
trope
of refugees as vectors of disease to
justify
increased surveillance and control um
through these
xenophobic and discriminatory policies
so on top of that we then have the
devastating explosion in beirut's port
on the 4th of august last year
which was believed to have been caused
by an impounded cargo of ammonium
nitrate stored for several years in a
warehouse without proper safety
precautions
and with major loss of life and
significant injuries
alongside the destruction to the port
and of roads this has made the emergency
delivery of aid supplies both very
important
but also increasingly difficult and
international donors
started to send aid including medical
supplies and
equipment to lebanon via the smaller
northern port of tripoli
which we'll be turning to shortly
um at that point this is august last
year
at this point the lebanese red cross
headquarters announces
that all of the groups hospital teams in
the north of the country would be
relocated to beirut
due to a shift in priorities and they
were needed to bolster medical capacity
to assist both blast survivors and the
dramatically increasing number of covert
19 patients in the capital
so bearing that background in mind um
it's now to the coronavirus pandemic
that
will turn shifting from beirut which has
been the focus of so much attention
to a small and relatively
under-researched urban refugee camp in
north lebanon
called badawi camp now but there we
refugee camp
was established in the early 1950s and
it is here that residents
have been supporting both and inverted
commas old and
new fellow refugees who share the camp
amidst
the multifaceted risks created by the
pandemic
and by the diverse responses to it
responses that include
unequal allocation of and access to
health care resources
in addition to anti-refugee political
referent uh rhetoric
and um policies so there are many ways
that we could introduce madari refugee
camp
but here i'll um draw on yusuf mustafa
kashmir's
poem writing the camp which i think
captures some of
its key dynamics so he writes
refugees ask other refugees who are you
who are we to come to you and who are
you to come to us
nobody answers palestinians syrians
iraqis kurds share the camp the same
different camp
the camp of a camp they have all come to
reoriginate the beginning
with their own hands and feet
and this reference to reoriginating the
beginning with their own
hands and feet is a very important
reminder
that for many people who've experienced
conflict and displacement
they are always already in the middle of
displacement they have to reoriginate
the beginning because
this is a recurring process in the case
of badawi refugee camp
about 15 000 palestinian refugees who
had previously been living in
birded refugee camp in lebanon were
internally displaced to
and subsequently hosted in badawi
following the destruction of
camp in 2007. this means that around ten
thousand
refugees from berid are now part of the
refugee community in badawi camp
who are hosting people who've been
displaced from syria
and who are responding to the needs and
the rights of the diverse residents of
badawi camp
so here we have internally displaced
refugees hosted by refugees who are
themselves hosting refugees
and this is a very important again
reminder of the precarity of the
situations that people live in
but also these intersecting processes of
displacement
and of hosting and of the multiple um
crises
effectively that people navigate in
their everyday lives and in the lives of
their families and those who live
around them now it was early
in 2010 as the coronavirus um started
to erupt in different different spaces
and in different guises
um that the residents of badawi camp
themselves started to await
with fear for the arrival of covet 19
um as kosmia writes in his poem with a
third eye i see the catastrophe so
i'll read his lines here as we wait for
the disease
in echoless rooms doors locked up
shutters dusted
thrust to the heart the disease that
will sign are pact with our diseases
in patients with a bereft of patients we
stand still behind our walls
without seeing we shall see the disease
that will be
with the third eye i see the catastrophe
and this fear has been borne out by the
un statistics
which in february of this year
documented
the palestinians covert 19 mortality
rate
is three times higher than the mortality
rate for the country as a whole
but importantly as we all know this
increased risk
and this increased mortality risk is not
because of displacement it isn't
inevitable
instead camp residents in lebanon are
acutely vulnerable to the impacts of
covert
19 because of living in overcrowded
urban camps with poor infrastructure
many residents are afflicted with
pre-existing health conditions that have
multiplied and worsened over time
due to amongst other things the fragile
honorable health systems which have been
defunded and weakened over decades by
fickle donors
while lebanese health systems have a
long history of discriminating against
and denying treatment to refugees
so against this backdrop it's not
surprising that mistrust amongst
palestinians and their fellow camp
dwellers
towards international and national aid
agencies and government departments
has remained very high as they have
faced covert 19
which leads us to the question well how
have the residents of badai refugee camp
responded to this imminent catastrophe
well indeed refugees in lebanon like
other displaced and dispossessed people
around
the world have drawn on long-standing
traditions of mutual aid and of
solidarity
to seek and to enact ways to protect
themselves and others from the pandemic
and i'll turn now briefly to some of
those responses
so the first example that i'll draw on
um
is from march 2020 so
this is more or less coinciding with um
politicians declarations that camps
are dangerous spaces and that camps
should be
closed off and that curfews should be
imposed by the government and
and enacted by lebanese security forces
um which did in fact take place across
the country
but on the 22nd of march last year the
debbie camps
joint security forces committee in
addition to the popular committee and
the mosques committee
jointly announced that a curfew would be
enforced on the camps residents and
businesses
and unlike previous curfews and camp
lockdowns of which there have been
many since the camp's establishment in
the 1950s
this curfew wasn't imposed by lebanese
authorities asserting that the camps are
sites of danger
instead because covert 19 cases had been
confirmed
in a neighboring area badawi camp
activists in fact
lobbied for the camps entrances and
exits to be closed in order to help
protect camp residents in badawi as in
other
displacement and hosting contexts
refugee camps are not
isolated spaces but instead are
intimately connected
to urban and non-urban areas beyond the
boundaries of the camp
so although palestinian camps have often
been perceived
as islands of insecurity to use rosemary
science term
in this context many camp residents
promptly identified the risks that
existed outside of the camp
and worked to encourage people to remain
within their homes
so a second example of camp-based
responses um
relates to information so anadwa had
been perceived as being very slow to
inform camp residents about the risks of
covert 19
and had also been perceived as being
very slow to provide different forms of
support
so members of the palestinian cultural
club in badawi camp or the badawi camp
cultural club as i'll refer to it now
they promptly took action drawing on
their intimate knowledge of camp life
and of everyday needs and rights in the
camp to
adapt existing evidence-based
informational posters including world
health organization materials
translating them into arabic
and sharing these posters and other
forms of guidance in print and via
social media
to reach camp residents of all
demographics in an accessible manner
in addition to running special programs
on its radio station
the cultural club worked with social
media networks that have been
established locally for years
these networks previously had been used
to inform residents about everything
from school closures to which areas of
the camp should be avoided
during armed clashes or sporadic
shootings
now coronavirus at this stage had not
entered the camp
but there was a very strong recognition
that although it wasn't visible
or audible in the way that these armed
clashes and sporadic
shootings had been in the past that it
was an equally significant
existential threat um to to residents in
the camp
so this sharing of information was um
was very important from their
perspective
by april um they also um increasingly
focused on food which of course is an
essential resource
and many camp residents have for a very
long time in the camp
tried to make sure that it's diverse
that the camp's diverse residents
receive enough food at different
junctures
of their lives and over the past few
years in preparation for the holy month
of ramadan
palestinian residents including members
of the cultural club
have collected financial donations from
other palestinians
to prepare iftar food baskets to break
the fast
during the month of ramadan to be
distributed to
residents identified as especially in
need whatever their nationality so
palestinian syrian iraqi kurdish or
lebanese
and irrespective of their place of
origin
in 2020 given the fears and the
restrictions on movement which arose due
to the pandemic
the organizers of these food baskets
were concerned that it would not be safe
for large numbers of people to go
door-to-door collecting donations
or to work together shopping for
ingredients cooking and subsequently
distributing hot meals during ramadan
but nonetheless the number of people in
need of food
has been much larger than in previous
years not just because of the pandemic
but also due to the ongoing collapse of
the already fragile
lebanese economy so the camp was able to
receive donations
sourced from from the camp itself and
from the neighboring areas
and started by distributing um food
boxes
and because of this concern that it
wouldn't be safe to
congregate and to prepare food and then
distribute it together
but then realized increasingly that for
many people who would particularly
benefit from receiving these food
baskets
and that they may not in fact have the
resources to be able to cook the food
they might not have the
um the the the cooking equipment they
might not have
fridges access to electricity um or
cooking stoves etc to be able to cook
this so the decision was made
to enact um food preparation in a safe
manner
and to subsequently distribute food um
through
respecting social distancing measures as
far as possible
so they adapted to this um changing
situation and expanded
a pre-existing um ramadan basket
initiative to ensure that the largest
number of people in the camp were able
to
access these these food baskets
but just a few days before the start of
ramadan
on april 23rd um as the limits of local
resources became increasingly apparent
the badawi camp cultural club um
chapters um
well the chapter in badawi but also the
cultural club chapter
in marilyaz camp joined an emergency
relief
fundraiser in partnership with a center
in gujarati camp
and also two u.s based palestinian
initiatives
the palestinian youth movement and the
palestine
right to return coalition and their aim
was to raise
50 000 u.s dollars to buy and distribute
packages of food and sanitizing project
products and in order to help residents
of those three camps
but there will be malayas and to be able
to practice social distancing and offset
some of the economic damage which had
been caused by the pandemic
and within three months this initiative
had exceeded that goal
that international um collaboration was
also supplemented
with the cultural clubs initiative which
was a who will donate a million
fundraising drive which was
um broad broadcast on their social media
channels and on the internet
now of course as i'm talking about this
it's an important
it's very important to note that need
and vulnerability
do not simply arise because of
displacement but rather to
remind ourselves that precarity is
produced and is not inevitable
so vulnerability to shocks and crises
will increase over time
and increase due to different crises
including um
the spiraling crisis of lebanon's
financial system
so here we have some of the key dates
which um exist or coincide with the
arrival of
covert 19 in uh in lebanon
with um bank transfers and bank
withdrawals being suspended in march
2020 and the closure of beirut airport
and the devaluation of the lebanese lira
all meaning that people were unable to
access
access money if they had access to
previously had access to bank accounts
they were unable to receive remittances
from
relatives and friends outside of lebanon
and whatever money they did have access
to um was
increasingly um unable to purchase the
goods
which themselves were also limited in
supply for different reasons
so here we see that the risk of people
becoming destitute and starving
is because of policies and political
decisions not just because of
displacement as it were
and ultimately social distancing is
impossible
for people who live in overcrowded
conditions who have no savings to draw
on to buy food and whose survival is
contingent
on precarious daily labor in the
informal sector
and indeed in lebanon national
authorities have long prohibited
palestinian
and syrian refugees from entering the
formal labour market
and that leaves them amongst the people
least likely
to be able to afford to practice social
distancing
therefore putting them at higher risk of
contracting the disease
so with this brief chronology that i'm
going through
um in fact by june 2020
there were these diverse camp-based
activities and camp-led
activities which have been taking place
in badawi camp
but at this point no palestinians in
lebanon had yet been confirmed as
contracting or having contracted covet
but unfortunately on 21st of june last
year
the state-run national news agency
reported that municipal testing of
syrian refugees working in tripoli's
port
had um indicated that a number of
syrians who lived in badawi camp
and on the camps outskirts had tested
positive
and at this stage um honorable
representatives
in conjunction with these media
declarations
um indicated that um the camp's
confirmed cases marked a significant
tipping point for the whole country
and one honorable representative stated
the epidemic
no longer just threatens our camps it
has now entered them
so at this stage we witnessed um
discriminatory processes including
nationality-based
testing um systems and these processes
led to honorable officials
implicitly asserting that the previously
clean and inverted camps
in inverted commerce camp was now at
risk due to the syrians infections
so syrian refugees were identified by
the authorities
and by the media as the vector of
disease and in turn
local actors in the camp including
palestinian factions
and the popular committee announced that
they had identified the location
of the two syrians living quarters
within badawi camp
and marked them as the epicenter of
contagion risk within the camp
at this time contact tracing was
immediately set in motion under the
supervision of the camps health
committee and the lebanese ministry of
health
which had committed to transferring any
individuals who tested positive to a
state hospital
but as these developments unfolded some
camp residents
started to associate covert 19 with
syrians in line with
the xenophobic rhetoric that had been
used by lebanese politicians at the
onset of the
pandemic and amid the raising
the rising fear of the arrival of the
virus
members of the popular and the security
committees started
roaming the alleyways and the streets of
the camp instructing people to shutter
their shops and to stay indoors
and badawi camp was once again subjected
to closure a space and a community in
quarantine
again this is a good point to step back
and to remember
that um local responses developed in
badawi camp
including those funded locally and those
supported through transnational networks
demonstrate the ways that camp residents
have worked individually and
collectively
to find ways to care for palestinian
syrian
iraqi kurdish and lebanese residents
alike
therefore transcending a focus on
nationality-based
identity markers and yet such modes of
solidarity and mutuality
have been placed at risk precisely due
to national and municipal interventions
that align with policies and with
political discourses
that have constituted the refugee other
as the threatening carrier of disease
and risk
so in essence tensions and hostility are
produced
not inevitable
so the final example that i'll give now
of refugee-led responses
arises in the context of the aftermath
of the devastating
august 2020 blast in beirut's port which
i referred to earlier
and this coincided with the coronavirus
infection rates soaring across lebanon
and with medical infrastructure
nationwide being under mounting pressure
so in autumn 2020 all of the red cross
and red crescent hospitals in north
lebanon started to relocate
with medical staff either being laid off
or moving to beirut in order to care for
both blast survivors
and for the rising number of covered 19
patients in the capital
and although although that focus on
beirut is very understandable given the
vast destruction
caused by the port explosion allocating
more resources to the capital has put
people
living elsewhere in the country at
greater risk citizens and refugees alike
so recognizing the increasing pressure
on medical infrastructure
and the national er amidst this national
emergency
and as infection rates and deaths
started to increase
in badawi refugee camp the badawi camp
cultural club approached local officials
in the
town of badawi in august to ask if they
could use one of the
municipalities ambulances in order to
take refugees with covert symptoms
to hospitals and the municipality
granted its approval
loaning the camp an ambulance that was
not being used at that time
so a member of the badawi camp cultural
club volunteered to collect people
who had suspected covert 19 infections
from both badawi camp and also the
neighbouring camp nadel berid
and volunteered to transport them to
hospitals in
tripoli and halban in some cases to the
rafika hadidi hospital in beirut where
the majority of covert cases have been
cared for so this palestinian refugee
driver
if we want to use that term wears hazmat
suit
and protective gear which have been
provided by the red cross and by the red
crescent society at the club's request
masks have been bought from local
supermarkets and from shops
both in the camp and from neighboring
areas
and by borrowing this ambulance the
cultural club has been using
what we would call or what yusef and i
called using the citizens tools in order
to assist
other refugees now in doing so the
camps cultural club and its members have
continued to improvise
with the limited available resources to
navigate entrenched in
inequitable systems such makeshift
measures however are not sustainable
and they are no substitute for the
health care resources that national
and local governments should be
allocating to the camps during this
crisis to protect both their residents
and the surrounding communities so
our interlocutors have consistently
noted that they celebrate the extent to
which local responses have been
developed
but they also reassert that these are
not sustainable and that in fact more
pressure needs to be applied to ensure
that the structural inequalities
um that prevent people from being able
to enact their own decisions and to be
able to protect their own lives
those structural barriers need to be
challenged and that more equitable
systems need to be developed
to provide people with access to um
meaningful access to medical supplies
medical care in addition to a fair
access to to the labor market for
example so these are structural issues
that need to be focused on
so in conclusion um documenting or
archiving
following um use of kasamir's term
these local responses is a vital means
of stressing the ways that people who
have been displaced
themselves seek to fill the gaps and to
redress inequalities that have been
created
and reproduced by national and
international actors alike
and well before covert 19 arrived in
lebanon
mutual aid initiatives in badawi camp
and of course elsewhere
had transcended nationality-based
identifiers to provide support to camp
residents
with wide-ranging backgrounds in turn
highlighting the importance of
critically examining the ways that
pre-existing support systems and
networks
are being affected both by the virus
itself and by the different policies and
politics
emerging in the context of the pandemic
including nationality-based testing
and overlapping crises such as the
beirut blast
so ultimately um discourses and policies
that demarcate the sanctity of the self
through the denigration of the other
heighten the dangers of politically
produced precarity
while undermining the potential for
solidarity in times of overlapping
precarities
however individuals communities and
civil society groups continue finding
and implementing those makeshift
measures
which aim to fill the gaps which have
been created by national
and international actors alike and in
essence
we cannot understand either the
vulnerabilities that people face in
displacement
or the responses that they are
developing without considering the ways
that local experiences of and responses
to displacement and other crises are
framed by
national and international systems
including
long-standing structural inequalities
and processes of marginalization and
exclusion
so the vulnerabilities that the
residents of badawi camp
palestinians and syrians alongside
iraqis kurds and lebanese
are facing are caused by political
failures that have deep historical roots
um and whose repercussions will continue
to be palpably felt
in both the near and the distant future
so thank you again so much for listening
and i'm very much looking forward to our
conversations
um and our discussions and i hope we've
got enough time now for
for some exchange um and i'd also like
to
encourage you to please join our
communities of conversation
both on the refugee hosts um platform
and on the southern responses to
displacement platform
and both of whose contact details you
can see on the slide
here which we'll just leave up for a
moment and then
i will stop sharing the screen and come
back
to see all of you now so thank you again
so very much for
listening thank you yes so thank you
very much
so i don't know if you have questions
you are
welcome to either put them on the
chat for us directly
so thank you very much for for you know
highlighting the structural
constraints that exist on everybody's uh
responses
i was i was really quite having
interesting interested in how
the degree to which for instance young
people lead the charge
in um in
changing the world um so the example
that you give of the driver for instance
is that
you know a younger driver that that that
decides to to to move forward for
instance uh
have you had any kind of like a insight
into
any generational uh engagement
if you don't mind me i know it's not the
war question but i'm really kind of
interested
in how um you know young people
themselves
um just either step up or or
or you know how how yeah how
like maybe they step step to change the
world or
or refuse to do so depending on the
generation
absolutely thanks catherine so in the
case of the badawi camp cultural club
it is a youth organization so it's an
organization that
caters for young people in the camp um
but a large number of the people who
organize events etc
are themselves anadwa teachers or
underwear
who are dissatisfied with the extent to
which underwear itself
is able or willing to address particular
gaps and therefore
takes it as a responsibility to to fill
those gaps in different ways
so here we have young people certainly
being very active but also working in
collaboration with
members of the community who wouldn't
traditionally be conceptualized as part
of the younger generation let's say
and so there are there are different age
groups working together
and there are also different initiatives
taking place so here i focused in on on
the
on the cultural club but there are also
different initiatives taking place
um including through through the mosque
which again
would or through the many mosques in the
camp which again would typically be
older generation whereas through the
camp um cultural club we have
um women and men working together from
different generations
to identify what some of these gaps
would be whether it's information
food financial resources sanitation
products um or stepping in to provide
those medical
medical resources or access to those
medical resources
um i'm looking forward to delving a
little bit more deeply into
into these questions um as you know with
aleister ager and
and many other colleagues we've been
looking at local-led responses to
displacement over the course of four
years
and unfortunately covid has hit us right
at the end of the project
but it really draws out the extent to
which
members of of the camp community of all
ages
um of all professions and of none take
different
responsibilities and make different
decisions on how to respond to these
overlapping precarities
i haven't answered your question very
clearly but thank you
sorry i have a question eleanor thank
you for your presentation i'm
um speaking from australia and i i'm
very familiar with the
asia-pacific kind of refugee-led
initiatives i've been involved in
in some of the more strategic advocacy
work that um
refugee leaders have been involved in
and i'm wondering in your context
how much the local level responses are
filtering up to sort of
the national level decision making is
there any access
by refugee-led organizations to
any of that sort of decision-making
beyond the camp but but actually where
the decisions are being made by red
cross for example
in the humanitarian coordination sort of
system
um and any comments you have about the
the politics of that i guess
from your experience so thank you thank
you louise thank you
this kind of comes back to catherine's
comment as well
you know to what extent younger people
want to change the world or
where where they see their forum and
their sphere of action
so for many different reasons the
cultural club doesn't have access and
probably isn't really seeking access to
governmental systems for example and as
i mentioned with
quite a lot of honorable staff actually
being involved in the activities
it's almost identifying the failures in
the in the system
and saying well what can we do to fill
the gaps that are not only left by the
system but often actually created by the
systems themselves
so i think this comes back to that
broader question of kind of a division
of labor
and division of the gaps um and where
different people feel that they can
fill those gaps often on through
horizontal cooperation
so one of the initiatives that i
highlighted there yes has transnational
support
from u.s palestinian initiatives but is
also working with other camp based
youth groups so whether it's the
medellias um cultural club um
or the bhuja badajna youth center
working together
to identify what are the common
struggles that we are facing across the
camps
and how can we work together with that
transnational support
to um to support um the the residents of
these camps situations
um of course there are many other people
who do want to
um have access to those systems and
those structures of power
and who will be applying for jobs um and
who will be lobbying
um ngos and the organizations that they
have access to
but the opportunities are certainly not
coordinated and supported in the way
that
uh refugee-led organizations are
increasingly having a platform
in specific un governmental and ngo
initiatives
um but we go back to that question of
whose voices are heard and how to what
extent is it a strategic incorporation
or actually a challenge to the status
quo and really
offering an alternative mode of
operating which doesn't just perpetuate
the humanitarian system
um itself so i'm really looking forward
to hearing more about
the the asia pacific um kind of examples
and how
that does or doesn't challenge those
those systems themselves and your work
is really important in that louisa
just i'm so struck by the tension of the
refugees who
are showing that they are capable they
are able to
offer the solutions to problems that
they're not simply a
social burden and yet not wanting to
um aggrandize themselves to the point
where it sort of like and so
you know there isn't still this existing
incredible inequality in other words
that that's a tension that i found in my
own field work in greece as well where
refugees are are saying yes we are we
can do it but also
this is an impossible task and and i
just you started to sort of talk a
little bit about that towards the end
and i just wanted to get more
i don't know ethnographic grounding and
what your some of the specifics if you
give us some
so that i love the image that you had of
the of the chords
all wrapped around this stick and you
just you know people are so creative and
yet it's so fundamentally
um unfair and wrong the way resources
are shared or hoarded yeah
no absolutely and as you say your
research in in greece demonstrates this
remarkably clearly
so this is a tension i think that arises
in so much of our research
where we we recognize of course the
agency that people have
and we in my case want to document the
work that people are doing and they are
resisting and they are
archiving their own responses and
they're doing the research and they're
demonstrating their capabilities to
conceptualize and to
develop different systems et cetera et
cetera not just to survive and to
stay alive that's that's not the basis
of
of their actions and yet at the same
time this recognition that it's not
sustainable
so if you think about um the the image
that i had of
of people from that had about it you
know these are internally displaced
refugees
hosted by other refugees now hosting
refugees if we if we recognize
displacement as being part of this
always already being in the middle of
displacement then it's thinking through
well what are the political
foundations for that crisis those crises
the overlapping precarities
and how do we in fact need a deeply
political response to this
rather than the constant depolitisation
of humanitarian crisis as if another
plaster is going to really fix it
so i think that it goes back to what um
i think that catherine was you know
identifying that i was stressing the
structural and i think that i am
stressing the structural
um precisely because of that tension in
my own research that i don't want to
suggest that
that the u.s or that the un has the
right to withdraw and to say
we don't have to be involved anymore we
don't have a responsibility because look
people are doing it themselves which is
effectively one of the tensions of the
localization of aid agenda it's saying
yes local communities
are doing this municipalities can do
this but they need the relevant forms of
support
not an abrogation of responsibility so
for me it's that combination of
documenting
what archiving what people are always
already doing
but highlighting that this is not
sustainable precisely because
it's if it's not going to be covered and
it's not going to be the beirut blast
it's going to be something else and you
can't expect people to continue
carrying that without addressing those
structural inequalities
i'm not giving you any ethnographic
detail in that response serena
um but i know that you you have done so
much research in this in this area as
well and i think it's more it's more
that tension you know even what's the
ethics what are the ethics of even
documenting what people are doing
how does that play into and potentially
reproduce this system of abrogating
responsibility
when these are intrinsically political
contexts
it's an unfair question because honestly
it's something i myself have not
resolved in my own work of
you know not wanting to kind of idealize
this incredible resistance
um you know without kind of that kind of
hard-hitting critique and i think you do
i learned from you always elena because
you do it i think very effectively here
and elsewhere
where you really do manage to keep us
thinking about both scales
that's really kind of you serena thank
you
can i just jump in there and i think i
mean i'm really loving this conversation
but i think that's maybe what i was
interested in terms of that structural
because i agree completely with what
and i recognize in in the organizations
that i work with here in
in the asia pacific the same the same
themes and the same frustrations and the
same sort of you're wanting to
highlight what they do because it's in
some ways it's breathtaking likely
creative and wonderful but other times
it's so frustrating to think that
how much work is and how much really
hard work is is done to try and even get
meager
things happening so my question is
really how do we change the systems as
well as
recognize the strengths and i think that
um how the
strategically um and not in and i think
you're right eleanor in terms of like is
it really representation and what does
it look like and who's
speaking and all those things which are
very complicated
um and is it actually shifting anything
but that's my
real question is how do we take what is
done at a local level
and also change systems and recognize
that
we don't want to shift responsibility
but bring people into that picture
so anyway thank you louise absolutely
i i don't think that i have the solution
certainly but i'm also not sure that i
should have the solution that's exactly
the point is that it shouldn't be me
in oxford in the uk saying this is what
the un should do but rather actually it
will
how do we listen how do we actually stop
and listen and deconstruct
and actually start an open
and equitable conversation around this
with the people who are not just
affected communities they are always
already responding
and the humanitarian system often
undermines those responses but won't
accept that
because it's also part of the survival
of the system
which has at its core the foundation or
the aim of
improving people's lives um but i think
that that that's the ongoing work it's
how to open up those equitable
conversations
in a way that is is willing to to
challenge the systems
um and we can go around in circles on it
but
i'm i'm not the right person to answer
it um
and but neither is necessarily one
person from badawi refugee camp
it's how we actually join up those dots
and how we have perhaps those examples
of horizontal
conversations and seeing what works and
what works to destabilize as well as
what works to construct
i think paul had a question yes
uh hi elena thank you for the
presentation i joined late uh i couldn't
actually connect i'm in lebanon now
and actually i uh we went through me and
my family through the
beirut blast however you know
i don't want to go there because that's
a that's a that would be a long
discussion
um i'm fi i'm currently finalizing my
phd at
ucl i'm a ucl yale scholar
and my ethnographic studies and my
investigation is about syrian refugees
so i know that they're very marginalized
i know that
through some findings that some
bottom-up approaches
were successful in a way even if
temporary
to let's say
strengthen the ties between host
community members and senior refugees
however when i visited and i actually
have a paper about that and i did some
ethnographic studies on the
bahi camp where you have palestinian and
then senior refugees where
recently i mean they recently joined
after the crisis
the camp is is there over 50 years and
the same thing
for andrew helwy uh i saw
and i noticed uh through the interviews
that senior refugees over there are even
marginalized by palestinian refugees
so there is like refugees to refugees
marginalization
which actually uh was an interesting
finding so the question is
because you know you're an expert in
that i'm more investigating the senior
refugees so the question is have you
found or noticed any bottom-up
approaches or any
mechanisms between palestinian and
and syrian refugees within those camps
to
strengthen the or let's say lessen
the marginalized marginalization between
the two parties
for example this this this club that you
just mentioned does it include senior
refugees
thank you thank you very much paul and
um i wish that ucl would open so that we
could meet and
have the conversation um there but um
thank you thank you for your question um
so absolutely
as zadina was saying in my research i
don't mean to idealize
responses from badawi refugee camp or
any of the
other places where i um speak with
people and
listen to what they're saying um but
rather to
explore those complex relationships and
what it means to actually focus on the
relationship between
palestinians and syrians or palestinians
and kurds palestinians and iraqis and
the multiple directionalities of
displacement and hosting that exist in
these situations
and certainly in my broader research i
do document and explore different
instances of
marginalization of discrimination and
exclusion
so that's certainly part and parcel of
those processes
there are many different initiatives
that do recognize that
and explicitly attempt to promote
social cohesion in that lovely ngo
language
um but also go beyond that and think
through
well we're all residents of this space
and if we take the neighborhood
or the camp as the call then it's
everybody who's in this space
who is a member of this organization or
who is involved in this particular
initiative
um and there are many many different
local responses which embody that
um and which attempt to challenge um the
discrimination
as i was suggesting in my presentation
today
discrimination hostility tension isn't
inevitable it's often
produced politically so the example that
i was given from baderi refugee camp was
of
i'm not sure at what stage you joined
but nationality-based testing in tripoli
port of syrian refugees
identified syrian refugees who lived in
badawi camp as
carrying covert 19 and of bringing it
into the camp
and of polluting the previously safe
camp
so here it's nationality-based testing
media reporting
political um declarations which leads to
the suspicion of of syrians as the
epicenter
and as as the bearers of of the disease
so if we recognize that
tensions hostility etc are produced
rather than inevitable then that's
precisely how
it can be challenged and it can be
deconstructed and again zarina's work in
in
in greece demonstrates the same that you
have strange alliances or what seem to
be strange alliances
and zadina can speak to this herself um
across political and ideological lines
from atheist and secular to to
faith-based
um responses etc um so
there definitely is marginalization
there definitely is discrimination just
as there is between different groups of
palestinians there's discrimination
between palestinians
who were born in badawi camp and
palestinians who've come from yarmouk
and you can identify where if it's a
palestinian from syria or a palestinian
from lebanon and there are multiple
forms of exclusion and marginalization
for me it's recognizing that it's not
inevitable and that there are multiple
ways of addressing it but it does come
back i think to the political on so many
different levels
um and i think it would be great zadina
would you like to come in
on that because this is you know the
core of so much of your research as well
yeah i mean i i love this point and you
know it seems like such a simple point
to say that these
uh conflicts are produced and not
natural and yet
when we look at the way that the ngos
think and the way
governments think they absolutely treat
these conflicts between refugees as
spontaneous and natural eruptions in the
camps
rather than things that are absolutely
produced by structures and so
i think as scholars sometimes i mean i
certainly have the feeling where i'm
just like
this is such a banal point should i keep
making this point
and then i hear elena make it so
powerfully again and i say oh my god yes
because people don't get this point they
think that
you know i mean in the camp that i was
working in greece
it was that the strollers go to the
kurds before they go to the afghanis
before they go to somebody else
and and then oh well why that and well
my you know i'm i had a baby and i
needed a stroller now and what
who who decides that why can't it just
simply be you know whoever needs a
stroller gets a stroller right what
what does this invocation of nationality
do and i think
i mean with the covet it's so powerful
to think of the ways in which they're
both though thank you sadina i don't
know if we got cut off there just at the
end
but thank you paul what what do you
what what do you think of that response
or those responses
i mean uh i mean it was obvious that the
ngos are exacerbating the the whole
tension
within the camp and within the host
community members
and but you know i was just curious to
see what what mechanism could have been
done to alleviate that between
palestinian and syrian refugees or other
refugees within the camps
because i didn't notice that much of
bottom-up approaches or
top-down approaches in that that were
successful
however actually based on on also my
research uh regarding covet 19
uh syrian refugees were actually
uh marginalized i'm talking about the
veka area this is where my research is
uh they were they were you know afraid
from the host community members to be
stigmatized and all that and then
actually no cases were
no cases were reported so it was the
it was the opposite way and they they
they worked very well with the
municipality uh they were able to
uh coordinate very well i mean the
xiaowish or i mean they were able to
find
you know to to found those uh internal
structural organizations that
communicate with authorities so it was
very successful
uh i mean till now yeah and now we have
more cases it's it's uh nationwide
uh but but i didn't see yet any
successful uh let's say mechanisms
that that brought this social cohesion
or social integration
yeah i think it also comes back to that
question of when you have to step in to
alleviate something
i think what zadina and i are suggesting
is that it's actually useful to go back
and to think about
how and why was this produced to begin
with rather than assuming that there is
a problem that needs to be fixed
by an external intervention and
so i think that's that's one response or
one thought process that i have
in relation to to what you're just
saying there and then i'm just going to
bring up a slide
from another presentation that i have
here and in terms of that notion of
success and what mechanisms might be
successful so zadine has seen this from
um a presentation that i gave at yale
a year two years ago now so this notion
of
what is visible and what is undisclosed
so a lot of our initiatives
so a lot of the initiatives that we've
been documenting are kind of below the
radar to a certain extent
so here what i call the poetics of
undisclosed care documented through
these three interview extracts
so we collected clothes we offered food
and cash to refugees but i hope you
don't mention this except for reasons
related to your research because we do
this only for god's sake
so that's a resident of badawi camp from
a syrian refugee living in badawi camp
those people who offer assistance
without disclosing their names
deserve respect and a kurdish refugee
from syria living in badawi camp
be like the good fruit that gives sorry
be like the good tree that gives its
fruits
and does not ask who took them so how do
we think about
what is successful what is visible what
is invisible in these um contexts
and there's definitely differentiated
care here's another another quote here
the differential response to residents
of natal berget camp being displaced to
badawi camp
as opposed to those um displaced from
syria something that's very well
documented and kind of discussed within
the camp
um again another example of
differentiated care
and then what i'm looking for here is
what we can think of as that notion of
success
which is coming back to that question
that you have so here is a syrian
who's living in badawi camp and they say
the local communities here in badawi
camp are also in a deplorable situation
and also suffer from poverty
they cannot meet their own needs how can
they provide in-kind and financial
assistance to others
we only ask them for good treatment and
non-discrimination between refugees on
the basis of their political
affiliations which was something that
had been happening in baderi camp at
that time
the institutions here are meant to
provide assistance and we would like
them to provide assistance in a
professional manner so this idea
of you know what what is considered to
be um enough
another um interview with another syrian
in badawi camp
um about which is kind of picking up on
this notion of caring or observing
i think that the biggest part of the
local community does not care about this
and their role does not transgress the
limits of observing
so the question that arises for me is
who determines
what is enough and what is a good
response or a not a not good enough
response so if we bear in mind the
poetics of undisclosed care on the one
hand
what is the necessity of care versus
observing for example
is it enough to observe um this kurdish
refugee from syria says it is enough
that they allowed us to live amongst
them despite this great population
pressure
in my view the local community is not
interested in providing us with
assistance
all they have to do is accept our
presence in these areas and to offer us
moral support
for me it is enough that my palestinian
neighbour greets me every morning and
that i go to work being sure that my
children are well amongst their foreign
neighbours
so it's not a response but it's a
question who decides what is enough
who decides if it's material support if
it's spiritual support
if it's greeting somebody in the
alleyway sharing that space
ensuring that the children are well
amongst their foreign neighbors
is being with or being together enough
from whose perspective and how do we
counteract that
when we think about how ngos come in and
say that what we need is social cohesion
and what we need is this kind of
response
this is what success looks like well
actually what does it look like
from conditions of structural precarity
what does it look like
from from the the perspective of
different people within the camps and
that's not to say that i
agree that that's enough you know i
might have an idealized vision of what
would work better
um but it's a more complex process i
think than identifying
this is the right mechanism this is
success success according to whom
success according to what markers of
visibility and action
i think there's some of the questions
that i have as i'm continuing to go
you know to read through the interview
transcripts that we have and bearing in
mind the ethnographic research that
myself and my teams have been doing as
well
so it'll be really fascinating to hear
more about your research
as it as it continues to develop um so
thanks for
for that question that conversation and
it's really lovely to be able to
have that discussion and that exchange
thanks paul
i have a question elena is like um
what have been like the
implication of what you have seen in
terms of
gender differences basically
um some of the
marginalization of women that you have
seen before how that has changed
now or i mean
what directions with the
pandemic and the
um other thing is about
now um in terms of the
vaccinations because i guess that even
like i guess in in every country we are
seeing now
sort of some groups being put
like at the end of the queue so how
uh you have seen that basically
um from the country that is
most likely stretch in terms of
vaccinating its own citizen
how well the
xenophobic views are probably reinforced
there um in term um with with the
vaccination now
okay thank you so i haven't looked
specifically
at gender dynamics with reference to
covid
um i've i've i haven't been able to
be in badawi camp obviously for a long
time um
so it's a kind of it's all from a
distance certainly there are
long-standing
um unequal um roles played by
women with reference to the destruction
of particular key services
in a space like the dewey so if we think
about school closures
so women are actively involved in
educating their children and supporting
their learning
with you know often multiple children of
different ages attempting to access
online learning
through you know the one mobile phone
or the the radio system that that might
possibly be giving them access so their
domestic
burdens are increasing their educational
um provision
um attempting to to keep people safe and
clean so
um all of those duties are
enhanced uh precisely because of of the
pandemic
the ability to to make do with very
small amounts of food available um how
you
change your entire domestic framework
around
cooking and keeping your family safe and
healthy and fed etc
they're all key issues um large numbers
of of women
who are um formal educators as well
and therefore are teaching just as many
of us
are you know teaching plus looking after
our families at home etc
um and the impact of the reduction of
informal labour opportunities
obviously um leaving men in particularly
vulnerable positions to exploitation as
well which
has certainly been documented in many
instances so syrian refugees for example
who were already
male refugees who are already at risk of
detention deportation
expulsion etc are even more at risk now
precisely because of curfews
because of lockdowns um because of those
people who are don't have the privilege
of
remaining indoors and um being
um you know respecting social distancing
rules
being more visible in the public sphere
and therefore more at risk
so i think there are different different
ways in which gender
relations have been affected and
particularly gendered vulnerabilities
have been
accentuated by by covert 19.
with reference to vaccinations in
lebanon and i'm sure that paul will be
able to give us a kind of more
up-to-date um
briefing from from beirut perspective um
i think a lot of us were very concerned
that palestinians and syrians would be
excluded from the vaccination rollout
but in fact shortly after the lebanese
politicians were first vaccinated in the
country
um vaccines were reaching um unhcr and
underwater distribution points
so um palestinian refugees have and
syrian refugees have been able to
register for vaccinations
there has been quite a bit of reticence
amongst lebanese citizens
so although there has been a push to to
vaccinate lebanese
um citizens the uptake potentially
hasn't been as high as many would have
expected
and there's been a particular buy out
system to ensure that un
systems were able to purchase and
distribute those vaccines
so thankfully there has been a
recognition that the public
health crisis requires vaccination of
all
and this is not immediately materialized
as discrimination against
um palestinian and syrian iraqi kurdish
refugees accessing the vaccine
so there is a roll out we'll have to see
how that how that continues
um but in in this case a relatively
small
so of course the per capita ratio of
refugees per
per citizen capital is very high in
lebanon but the overall population is is
relatively small when compared with many
other countries
so the capacity to actually roll out is
hopefully
um going to be um well we can only hope
that it's going to
go into work um in a broadly equitable
framework
um so maybe we'll have a better idea of
that in
in a couple of weeks where what are we
three
four weeks post the arrival of the
vaccine in lebanon so it is it is quite
early days
um i'm not sure if paul if you have a a
more up-to-date
um account of that i mean uh
the only update is like you know the
whole
rollout of the vaccine is of has been a
flop by the lebanese government however
it is
uh everybody is equated so it is open
for everybody
which which is actually a good sign but
we as lebanese citizen now we feel
ourselves as refugees as well uh
within the system so i mean when you see
that the deputies of your country
just got vaccinated uh you know
i went through the official platform and
everybody is waiting
so the amount of vaccines that arrived
here
is not enough it's it's very low
but yes uh the good thing that you know
everybody
uh not only not only through
vaccinations actually everybody can be
admitted to hospitals if needed
the hadith state hospital uh whether
you're living is syrian or palestinian
uh but the vaccination till now it's
it's
it is a flop and it is within the
corrupt system of the government
do we have any more questions or
comments
or points of conversation
i think probably i would like to
just mention i mean
with respect to the vaccination in a
completely different
setting in latin america with the
venezuelan refugees
um that actually the
because um
non-registered venezuelans do not have
access to the for example the colombian
health care system the
need to vaccinate them
just brought
basically a legalization program
now of around one million people
um a million refugees so
just i mean at least
in terms of the offer and even if the
supply is low for
for everybody because the vaccination
program is just started as well as in
lebanon so
at least and and that was completely
political well not completely political
decision because
the first reaction was not to vaccinate
the
refugees but there was like an outcry
and then that brought to the change so
um i guess probably in that respect is
uh sort of reassuring seeing that
uh um
that behavior but maybe as you
say is maybe working i mean see what is
the uptake
as well because
even i mean in all the countries we have
seen
also from minorities in general so
perfectly the law take up the vaccine
yeah absolutely and the extent to which
for example in the uk there are a
grave concerns that with the hostile
environment
um pervading medical settings that
people who have irregular status
will will not risk they won't risk
having
prenatal or birthing assistance
um they won't attend for vaccinations
for their infants
and let alone will they expose
themselves potentially to detention and
deportation
on the basis of accessing covert vaccine
vaccines so absolutely the hostile
environment
the the criminalization of people with
different legal backgrounds
creates again creates these inequalities
and creates
these um these public health issues
so we can we can only hope there are
increasing countries which are
ensuring that there is access um
vaccination access for
people with with refugee backgrounds um
that i was seeing um and yvonne might
might speak to this
um in canada for example the adverts
that are
being circulated catherine clark kazak
has been discussing this on twitter
refers to all canadians are eligible for
the vaccine which excludes people
who aren't necessarily citizens so even
how the terminology is used who is
included or excluded
when in fact migrants and refugees are
eligible for the vaccine but the
terminology that is being used is
exclusion it is excluding people
um and as i said i don't know if yvonne
um has any
um comments from her own research as
well um or from her reflections on on
the situation in
in canada ah yes thanks elena for uh
speaking about that um yes there's been
some discussion of that
and then i think in general there's a
there's a lot of discourse by the prime
minister of um canada justin trudeau
about this narrative of we're all in
this together
which has upset um a lot of people um
because of course
we understand that um we're not all in
this together there's a lot of
inequalities uh that exists so this type
of discourse um
has been upsetting people because it's
been taking place also at all different
levels
of the government as well in general a
lot of vaccine confusion
everybody is all over the news everybody
is quite upset
about how it's getting rolled out what
systems are being used
people are trying to line up and uh and
that's
that's of no help because they're
supposed to make phone calls you make
phone calls and um you can't get through
because everybody is also
on the line trying to sort it out so
yeah cad is not a great example
thank you again kind of disrupting the
assumptions that
erupted so early on in the covered
pandemic that certain countries would be
well prepared
and the reds you know the red zones of
where there would be
greater crises hasn't necessarily
corresponded with that geopolitics of
the imagination of health and infirmity
okay um so as i think uh
we reach the end of this conversation so
thank you very much uh for the
presentation elena
and um yes if i guess
we'd like
to yeah
just to
contact you i mean on this topic uh
or yeah and also basically
sort of expand the community of people
researching thank you very much
thank you so thank you all for for
joining and for staying on thank you
lovely to see you all thank you